[Music]
good morning Hank it's a Tuesday in
November Hank I still have a bit of an
ear infection but as several helpful
viewers pointed out to me last week I
never really had any facial symmetry so
that's good Hank I want to talk to you a
little bit today about the writer's
strike that's going on partly because
it's affecting my television habits and
partly because I'm worried about its
larger implications for creative work in
the United States so Hank when you write
books for a living it's a pretty simple
economic model this is my book every
time I sell one of these they pay me for
it I have a publisher the publisher
sells and distributes copies of my book
and for each book that is sold the
publisher makes a certain amount of
money and I make a certain amount of
money the amount of money I make is
smaller and it doesn't matter the format
the book is in it doesn't matter if it's
a paperback it doesn't matter if it's on
CD it doesn't matter if it's on tape or
if it's on mp3 or if it only exists on
the Internet but anyway the percentage
of a sale I get on various forms of my
book might change but I always get some
kind of percentage so that percentage is
called a royalty in screenwriting and
writing for television there's an
analogous percentage which is called a
residual it's called different things
because the studio actually technically
owns the copyright on screenwriting but
it's very complicated copyright law crap
now Hank I have to say to be fair that
there is one version of my book for
which I am NOT paid a penny it's called
an advanced readers copy and they give
this out to librarians and independent
booksellers and also to reviewers in
order to get people excited about the
book in the months before it comes out
see it says right there advanced readers
copy not for sale
Hank there is a reason I don't get paid
anything for this book it's because
they're given away and things that are
given away are basically promotional
tools right but here's the crazy thing
Hank when people write for television
shows and then those television shows
are put on the internet and then people
watch those television shows on the
internet while also looking and clicking
on ads that are on the same Internet
page the producers say that the writers
shouldn't get paid for that content
because its promotional content so let
me give you an example Hank say you
think Family Guy is funny I happen not
to but say you do you can go into
MySpace and you can watch an episode of
Family Guy an entire episode with
commercials and Fox will make money off
that content because they own myspace
which is showing ads and they also own
Family Guy which is also showing ad
and yet Fox says that they shouldn't
have to pay the writers to show the
stuff on MySpace because its promotional
content but Hank you can't make money on
promotional content and if you do make
money on it it's not promotional anymore
it's just content Hank you just as I'm
paid for mp3s and for audiobooks and for
paperbacks and for hard covers writers
want to be paid for their work on
television and in movies regardless of
the format whether it's shown on
television or on a movie screen or on
MySpace or on YouTube
that's all they want Hank is to be
treated like authors who for the record
are treated alright but you know not
that well now Hank the other argument of
the producers is that they can't set a
residual rate because they don't know
how much money they're going to make off
Internet content do you think brilliance
audio knows how many copies of the mp3
they're gonna sell if my book and
abundance of katherines of course they
don't Hank they could sell four copies
in fact I think they have the point is
whether you sell four or four million
you pay a percentage of your revenue to
the creator of the content that way we
all have a shared responsibility in both
the failure and the success of whatever
we create so seriously guys I would
appreciate it if you would go back to
the negotiating table and make a deal so
I can announce some very exciting news
to the nerdfighters tank I'll see you
tomorrow
Hank two quick pieces first the
nerdfighters a nerdfighter like an out
of themselves in an adorable video that
you can see here or possibly here and
there's always the chance that it's over
here also Hank thanks for your great
video yesterday about the scavenger hunt
it was extremely funny and a lot of
nerdfighters were also extremely
confused Hank I will say this the
scavenger hunt as a whole is very
complex but each day's clue can be
solved with almost no knowledge of
anything having to do with the scavenger
hunt before today by the way Hank
today's clue is going to be a doozy
nerdfighters
your clue is winter South Dakota